직교정규 집합은 단순히
단위 벡터들의 직교 집합이에요.
직교 집합의 벡터들은 반드시
단위 벡터일 필요는 없고, 사실 영 벡터가
직교 집합의 원소일 수도 있지만, 직교정규 집합에서는 모든 벡터가 단위 벡터여야 해요.
집합이 직교 집합이라는
요구 사항에 더해서요.
내적과 유클리드 노름 사이의 관계를
알고 있으니, 이 조건을 여기 보이는 것처럼
꽤 간결하게 표현할 수 있어요.
여기 보이는 것처럼요.
그리고 마지막으로, 직교정규 기저는 단순히
우리가 다루는 벡터 공간에 대한
기저를 형성하는 직교정규 집합이에요.
예를 들어, 어떤 고전적 상태 집합
시그마를 취하고 모든 표준 기저 벡터의
집합을 생각하면,
이것이 직교정규 집합이고, 사실 이 고전적 상태 집합 시그마에 해당하는 성분을 가진 모든 벡터의 공간에 대한 직교정규 기저라는 것을 알 수 있어요.
이것들은 모두 단위 벡터이고
쌍으로 직교하니까 직교정규 집합이에요.
기저이기도 하니까 직교정규 기저예요.
직교정규 집합은 항상 선형 독립이에요.
그래서 직교정규 집합이 있으면
항상 어떤 부분 공간에 대한 직교정규 기저가 될 거예요.
하지만 이 경우에는 우리가 작업하는 전체 공간에 대한 기저예요.
또 다른 예는 Ket+와
Ket-를 포함하는 집합이에요.
이 두 벡터는 직교하고, 내적이 0이에요.
둘 다 단위 벡터이고 단일 qubit에 해당하는
2차원 벡터 공간을 생성하니까,
이 공간에 대한 직교정규 기저를 형성해요.
또 다른 예는 Bell 기저인데, 이것은
두 qubit에 해당하는 모든 4차원 벡터의
공간에 대한 직교정규 기저예요.
반면에, Ket 0과 Ket+를 포함하는
집합은 직교 집합이 아닌데, 이 벡터들 사이의 내적이 0이 아니기 때문이에요.
둘 다 단위 벡터이고 qubit에 해당하는 벡터 공간의 기저이지만, 직교성이 없어요.
여기 가끔 활용할 직교정규 집합에 대한 편리한 사실이 있어요.
어떤 직교정규 벡터 집합이 있다고 가정해요.
구체적으로, 이 집합에 M개의 벡터가 있다고 합시다.
Psi 1부터 Psi M까지인데,
이 벡터들이 어떤 N차원 벡터 공간에서 가져온 것이라고 가정해요.
다시 말해, 각 벡터가 M개의 성분을 가지고 있어요.
이미 언급했듯이, 직교정규 집합은 항상
선형 독립이니까, M이 N보다 클 수 없어요.
하지만 M이 N보다 작을 수는 있고,
그것이 우리가 관심 있는 경우예요.
이 사실이 말하는 것은 M이 N보다 작으면,
우리 공간에 대한 직교정규 기저를 얻기 위해
시작한 집합에 추가적인 벡터를
항상 추가할 수 있다는 거예요.
정확히 말하면, 벡터 Psi M+1부터 Psi N까지가
반드시 존재해서 전체 모음이
직교정규 기저를 형성해요.
그러니까 말하자면, 직교정규 기저로 확장할 수 없는
직교정규 벡터 집합을 선택해서
궁지에 몰리는 일은 절대 없어요.
때로는 시작한 집합을 보고 직교정규 기저로 확장하는 방법을 알아낼 수 있지만, 항상 작동하는 대안은
그람-슈미트 직교정규화 과정이라는
절차를 사용해서 이런 벡터들을 구성하는 거예요.
이 수업이나 이 시리즈에서 그 절차를
설명하지는 않을 건데, 세부 사항이 우리에게
별로 중요하지 않기 때문이에요. 하지만 궁금하시면 찾아볼 수 있어요.
이것은 컴퓨터가 수행할 수 있는 것이에요.
그래서 창의성은 필요 없고,
그냥 기계적인 절차예요.
이것이 이렇게 편리한 사실인 이유 중 하나는
직교정규 기저와 유니터리 행렬 사이에
존재하는 밀접한 관계와 관련이 있어요.
특히, 어떤 정방 행렬 U에 대해, 여기 보이는 세 가지 조건은 항상 동치예요.
즉, 모두 참이거나
모두 거짓이에요.
첫 번째 조건은 U가 유니터리 행렬이라는 것인데,
이것은 U 대거 곱하기 U와 U 곱하기 U 대거가 모두
항등 행렬과 같다는 뜻이에요.
두 번째 조건은 U의 행들이
직교정규 기저를 형성한다는 것이고,
세 번째 조건은 U의 열들이
직교정규 기저를 형성한다는 거예요.
이 동치가 왜 성립하는지
보는 것은 사실 그렇게 어렵지 않아요.
간단하게 하기 위해, 여기 보이는
3x3 행렬 U를 살펴봅시다.
성분은 원하는 어떤 복소수든 될 수 있어요.
여기 왼쪽에 편의를 위해
U의 켤레 전치를 적어놨어요.
U의 열로부터 세 벡터를 만들면,
여기서 Psi 1, Psi 2, Psi 3이라고
이름 붙였는데, U 대거와 U의 곱을 취하면,
곱의 각 성분이 여기 이 패턴에서
보이는 것처럼 벡터들의 내적으로 주어진다는 것을 확인할 수 있어요.
U가 유니터리라는 조건을 생각하면, 이것은 이 행렬이 항등 행렬과 같다는 것과 동치인데,
세 벡터가 직교정규 집합을 형성하는 것과
동치라는 것을 알 수 있어요.
대각선 성분이 모두 1이어야 하니까
반드시 단위 벡터이고, 비대각선 성분이
0이어야 하니까
벡터들의 직교 집합이에요.